sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßte
herzlich los geht's mit einer frage des
heutigen tages herr lindner putin greift
nun seinerseits zu sanktionen gazprom
germania wird nicht mehr beliefert das
wissen wir seit heute wie beunruhigt ist
die bundesregierung was wissen sie über
diese russischen gaslieferung
wir wissen dass einzelne unternehmen
jetzt nicht mehr beliefert werden die
größenordnung ist für den deutschen
gasverbrauch aber beherrschbar sind ja
ohnehin dabei unsere versorgung auf eine
breitere basis zu stellen und nach und
nach unabhängig zu werden von russland
die größenordnung die es jetzt geht die
hat eine auswirkung gewiss auf die
preisentwicklung aber nicht auf die
versorgungssicherheit ich sage offen wir
sind auch vorbereitet auf fälle dieser
art und da auch eine nächste stufe zu
ziehen das wird in der regierung aber
noch nicht erwogen weil es versorgungs
unsicherheit noch nicht gibt was man es
mit nächste stufe sie meinen die
zuteilung vergaß das ist gegenwärtig
nicht notwendig es ist bezogen auf den
jahresgesamtbezüge
prozent größenordnung erste schätzungen
waren drei prozent des jahresbedarfs
deutschland entfallen jetzt durch diese
sanktion von putin das können wir
verkraften
klar ist aber es handelt sich um eine
neue form der wirtschaftlichen
auseinandersetzung mit russland die auch
deutschland betrifft wir dürfen uns
nicht in sicherheit wiegen sondern wir
müssen mit großer anstrengung weiter
daran arbeiten so schnell wie möglich in
möglichst allen fällen unabhängig zu
werden von russland damit wir nicht
erpressbar sind wir haben es momentan
liebe zuschauer das ist nun wahrlich
nichts neues mit einer vielzahl an
krisen zu tun corona dieser krieg
ehrgeizige klimaziele diese krisen
kommen nicht hintereinander sie lösen
einander nicht ab sondern sie geschehen
im grunde zeitgleich
6 prozent mehr für lebensmittel
18 prozent für strom
29 für gas und 107 prozent mehr für
heizöl als letztes jahr die inflation
7,4 prozent im april die verschiedenen
krisen kombinieren sich stürmen sich
übereinander
langfristig schmelzen die rücklagen der
sparer und sozial schwache stürzen in
blanke existenznot
annäherungen an das a wort
der staat kann
steigende kosten für energie importe
nicht auf dauer kompensieren energie zu
importieren zu höheren preisen zu
importieren bedeutet ja dass wir ein
stück gewissermaßen ärmer werden dass
wir mit wissenschaftlern darüber
diskutieren was das für das ökonomische
modell unseres landes bedeutet nichts
weniger als das fundament des deutschen
wohlstands ist bedroht mit billiger
energie hochwertiges made in germany
produzieren und exportieren
der krieg bringt das deutsche
geschäftsmodell ins stottern mit
dramatischen folgen
wenn morgen die chemische industrie
stillsteht gibt es weder für die
pharmazeutische industrie noch für die
landwirtschaft ammoniak es gibt keine
hightech kunststoffe und lager für
windkrafträder keine batterien für
elektroautos und keine dämmstoffe für
die energetische gebäudesanierung
wir schaffen das ist die botschaft der
ampel männer für eine andere scheint die
zeit noch nicht reif
zumutungen und verbote
karl häuschen ist bei uns präsident des
verbandes der maschinen- und
anlagenbauer baut sich da ein
sturm zusammen ist das eine toxische
nicht
toxische mischung in dem sinne dass wir
am ende des tages vergifteter nieder
liegen glaube ich nicht es lohnt sich
auch insbesondere der nach diesem
dramatischen intro dass sie gerade
gezeigt haben auf ein paar andere sachen
hinzuweisen wenn wir auf die
arbeitslosigkeit in deutschland schauen
ist eher niedrig wenn wir auf die
beschäftigung in deutschland schauen ist
sehr hoch wenn wir auf die
unternehmensgewinne im jahr 20 21
schauen wenn wir auf die
quartalsergebnisse im jahr 2022 schauen
im jetzt halt dann sehen wir auch viele
positive zeichen aber in diese kirche in
gefahr oder sehen sie diese gefahr nicht
der blick nach vorne ist natürlich sehr
viel skeptischer es gibt eine ganze
reihe von abwärtsrisiken die meisten
haben sie genannt es gibt auch ein paar
aufwärtschancen die großen
konjunkturprogramme die in der eu die in
den usa gestartet werden bieten durchaus
auch chancen sie haben das darf ich
verraten weniger jetzt in ihrer firma
mit russland verbindungen russland
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu tun als mehr
mit denen nach asien und china
was tun sie jetzt wie reagieren sie in
ihrer firma dar es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche betroffenen halten ist
wichtig dass der maschinenbau sehr viel
stärker mit china verbunden ist als mit
russland wirft der ukraine zusammen als
markt machen weniger als drei prozent
unseres geschäfts aus so dass der
wegfall dieses marktes verkraftbar ist
mit china schaut das ganz anders aus und
ich glaube das ganz ganz viele
unternehmen und unser unternehmen gehört
dazu sich ganz bewusst mit plänen
beschäftigen wie sie entweder ihre
kinder abhängigkeit reduzieren können
oder bei einem rückgang des chinesischen
marktes reagieren können strategisch das
steht auf der tagesordnung das tun sie
jetzt will kommen dazu noch konkreter
veronika grimm ist bei uns ökonomen eine
der wirtschaftsweisen dieses landes
vergrämen noch vor jahresfrist waren
sich die kollegen fast einig zu sagen
diese inflation wird eine temporäre
seien die wird genauso schnell mit dem
wachstum nach corona wie der aufgrund
überwunden sein sind wir in einer
situation zu verstehen die ist jetzt
gekommen um zu bleiben
zum einen waren sich die kollegen schon
ende letzten jahres gar nicht so
eigentlich viele haben gesagt dass ich
das verfestigen würde von den
energiepreisen reingehen würde in die
kerninflation einfach deswegen weil
natürlich die unternehmen irgendwann
auch diese hohen energiekosten
weitergeben weil man auch gesehen hat
dass die lebensmittelpreise steigen
würden zum beispiel deswegen weil du
nimmt düngemittel teurer werden und weil
dadurch auch die lebensmittel produkte
kreiert und nicht genau da gab es den
krieg noch nicht aber da gingen die
negative durchaus schon auseinander wir
können jetzt nicht mehr feststellen wer
recht halte die fraktion gesagt hat das
würde sich verfestigen die fraktion
gesagt hat das würde sich nicht
verfestigen ich habe schon länger gesagt
es würde durchaus man muss durchaus
reagieren jetzt ist es natürlich so dass
wir tatsächlich in einer sehr
herausfordernden lage sind die inflation
ist hoch die tarifverhandlungen stehen
bevor wir haben signifikante
reallohneinbußen also es ist zu erwarten
dass die lohnabschlüsse hoch sein werden
und es gilt jetzt wirklich die
inflationserwartungen also ja die
erwartungen der menschen der unternehmen
wie hoch die inflation mittelfristig
bleibt die gilt es zu verankern wenn die
inflationserwartungen steigen dann kann
es eben sagen dass ich eine
lohn-preis-spirale ergibt dass sich die
inflation sozusagen dynamisiert und dann
auch geldpolitisch sehr schweren griff
zu kriegen ist und es ist immer besser
geldpolitisch sehr früh dran zu sein
dass man eine weiche landung hin gericht
ohne rezession als dass man spät dran
ist und dann geldpolitische vollbremsung
machen muss dann wäre die gefahr einer
rezession deutlich größer also man kann
sagen dass wir jetzt genug dass wir früh
genug dran sind ist es so interessant
dass ausgerechnet in dem ersten
statement schon die lohn preis spirale
um die ecke kommt die als mini frisch
gewählte chefin des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes sie haben in ihrer
intro rede
sehr beherzt gesagt kommt mir bloß nicht
mit der lohn-preis-spirale
wie hoch denken sie um dann jetzt gleich
zu fragen wie viel verständnis wird es
auf der seite der arbeitnehmer geben in
dieser multi krise
vielleicht gehe ich einfach kurz darauf
ein warum ich sage kommt mir bloß nicht
mit der lohn-preis-spirale weil die
inflation sich natürlich nicht
aufgrund der löhne entwickelt wie sie
sich entwickelt sondern aufgrund der
preissituation und die ursache für die
inflation ist die lieferketten
unterbrechung sind die rohstoffpreise
sind zum teil spekulationen auch wenn
ich an das öl denke und das heißt es
bedarf dann natürlich auch sachgemäßer
instrumente jetzt die inflation
austragen zu wollen auf dem rücken der
beschäftigten durch reallohneinbußen
würde nichts anderes heißen als erneut
durch einen krise zu gehen mit einem
management das am ende sagt
wir müssen über die löhne quasi abfedern
was es jetzt halt zu schultern geht gilt
und das werden wir natürlich nicht
mitmachen
es wäre auch unsachgemäß weil wir vor
allem jetzt nicht nur die inflation
bekämpfen müssen sondern alles dafür tun
müssen um nicht noch zusätzlich in eine
rezession zu fallen und das heißt sie
müssen die wirtschaftskraft sie müssen
die kaufkraft stärken
auch dafür ist macht es sinn die löhne
jetzt halt auch tatsächlich nochmal mit
anzuheben wie sie ungefähr alle brauchen
sie investitionen
der staat darf nicht wie ein kleiner
kämmerer daherkommen sondern muss jetzt
als investor auch in diese krise
einstellen herr lindner ist gleich dran
der bundeskanzler hat auch vor dem krieg
frau vreni diese zeit in der wir leben
als eine nächste industrielle revolution
ausgerufen weil es wirklich ein riesiger
transformationsprozess ist der parallel
dazu vor uns steht um eben unabhängig
wählten zu werden von fossiler energie
werden wir das noch schaffen wenn wir
jetzt so viel geld für anderes ausgeben
müssten beispielsweise für die rüstung
wir werden schaffen müssen das ist
nämlich das einzige worauf unser
wohlstandsmodell am ende des tages hat
auch basiert und die diese ist
neuzeitlicher apollo projekt von dem
manche sprechen ja da sage ich da chor
genau das muss uns jetzt gelingen aber
nochmal umso mehr gilt es jetzt auch und
so habe ich die bundesregierung auch bis
jetzt verstanden diese fortschritts
projekte die sich zu eigen gemacht hat
sogar mit noch mehr dynamik nach vorne
zu bringen ich glaube die
herausforderung wird sein ob in
ausreichendem maße nicht nur in berlin
entschieden wird sondern ob tatsächlich
auch ganz praktisch umgesetzt wird in
den regionen wo jetzt die struktur
entwicklung passieren muss und da müssen
die akteure an einen tisch die am ende
des tages auch das wissen und das können
dafür haben das sind die arbeitgeber das
sind die beschäftigten mit ihren
interessensvertretung der gewerkschaften
wir wissen welche fachkräfte wir haben
weil von trainer diese welche nicht und
wie sie auch vielleicht umgeschult
werden müssen und die wm muss mit an
diese regionalen transformations-
beirats beiräte tisch damit aber auch
tschuldigung ja damit daneben auch die
qualifizierung auch sachgemäß erfolgen
kann jetzt sind wir werden ja in den
regionen sehr unterschiedliche antworten
finden müssen
um einen punkt machen weil wir kommen ja
eigentlich von einem doch noch ein
bisschen größeren sehr aktiv machen das
ist immer gut dazu kommen wir auch noch
herr lindner sie sind einer der wenigen
aus der ampel ich komme noch mal auf den
ursprünglichen gedanken zurück sie sind
einer der wenigen minister dieser
regierung der so eindeutig gesagt hat
die ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen
also all unsere unterstützung unsere
militärische unsere wirtschaftliche
unterstützung die möglich ist unter
diesen drei bedingungen wir kennen sie
muss in die ukraine jetzt werden wir
auch noch wahrscheinlich in naher
zukunft mit weniger gas konfrontiert
sein mit anderen
mängeln konfrontiert sein was glauben
sie wielange wird der atem reichen ich
frage das ganze eher emotional was
glauben sie wielange wird die
bevölkerung dieses landes sagen das ist
eine richtige entscheidung das machen
wir mit auch wenn dieser krieg
anderthalb jahre dauert oder wenn er
zwei jahre dauert wir sind dabei
die ukraine ist angegriffen worden weil
sie sich für
unsere art der lebensführung unsere
werte die liberale demokratie die offene
gesellschaft die soziale marktwirtschaft
europäischer prägung entschieden hat und
gegen die autoritäre politik von putin
gegen eine zukunft als satellitenstaat
russland 60 deshalb verteidigt die
ukraine auch unsere werte und aus diesem
grund haben wir nicht nur aus gründen
der solidarität sondern auch aus
wohlverstandenem eigeninteresse
die den dringenden rat die ukraine dabei
zu unterstützen ihr recht auf
selbstverteidigung zu verwirklichen
unsere unsere stärke ist die
wirtschaftliche substanz deutschlands
deshalb können wir solidarisch sein
deshalb können wir den sozialen frieden
bei uns sichern deshalb können wir unser
militär ertüchtigen deshalb können wir
die ukraine militärische stärke der
vergangenheit ist ja über unsere
deutsche wirtschaftliche stärke oft ein
bisschen verächtlich gesprochen worden
und braucht man überhaupt noch wachstum
in deutschland ist das nicht alles genug
wir sehen jetzt ist ein vorteil und den
müssen wir auch ausbauen
ich glaube dass die warnung von frau
grimm vor der lohn-preis-spirale sehr
berechtigt ist aber diese warnung darf
nicht missverstanden werden von den
gewerkschaften sie sollten jetzt auf dem
rücken der beschäftigten
hinnehmen dass es reale
kaufkraftverluste gibt es würde frau
grimm auch nie so sagen ich auch nicht
ich sehe etwas anderes was wir jetzt in
der krise tun müssen da hat der staat
eine rolle durch entlastungspaket wie
wir sie jetzt ja gerade schnüren für die
beschäftigten auch für die menschen die
grundsicherung entfernen 100 euro
kindergeld
versuchen wir ja eines den aktuellen
verlust an kaufkraft durch eine
staatliche maßnahme zu dämpfen in diesem
jahr damit die gewerkschaften nicht
komplett alleine über tarifforderungen
zu lasten der unternehmen und ihrer
wettbewerbsfähigkeit die inflation
bekämpfen müssen das heißt der staat
versucht die
inflationserwartung für die
tarifverhandlungen stück zu dämpfen
damit wenn ich in so einen automatismus
kommen wir können froh sein ist einer
unserer standortvorteile wir haben sehr
verantwortungsbewusste gewerkschaften in
deutschland
ich denke mal an die
industriegewerkschaft bergbau chemie und
energie die jetzt gerade an an eine
brückenfinanzierung bis in den herbst
mit einmalzahlungen verabredet haben um
eben auch nicht in eine solche spirale
zu kommen gestatten sie mir noch eine
letzte ganz kurze bemerkung auch noch zu
frau familien die sagte wir dürfen jetzt
nicht wie ein kleiner kämmerer haben sie
gesagt ich fühle mich nicht angesprochen
weil wir bis 2026 als bundesregierung
350 milliarden euro an öffentlichen
investitionsmittel vor sind so viel wie
jetzt kommt mein punkt warum ich glaube
wir dürfen uns ein bisschen optimismus
doch leisten das geld ist da 350
milliarden öffentlichen
investitionsmittel nicht mein geld ihr
geld unser aller geld das problem wird
sein frau fahimi dieses geld sinnvoll
einzusetzen weil in deutschland der
bürokratismus die planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren zu lang dauern und
hier ist meine zuversicht wenn aus
dieser schwierigen situation der
verschachtelten krisen wir es schaffen
in deutschland unsere planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
wenn wir weil wir russland kritisch
sehen andere auf der welt jetzt mit
anderen augen vielleicht auch sehen ohne
sie vergleichen zu wollen weltweit mit
unseren wert partnern auch stärker
handel treiben wenn wir unser
wirtschaftsmodell erneuern richtung
sauberer technologie und so weiter und
so fort dann haben wir auch eine chance
aus dieser krise gestärkt hervorzugehen
so das ist teil ihres strategiepapier
ist da wollte ich auch ganz kurz noch
mal fragen wann wir dann dazu kommen so
strategisch zu denken und vor allen
dingen sie weil es noch mal ja ein
großer batzen von krisen ist die wir
alle erst mal mit geld lösen herr linden
also von den flüchtlingen bis zu den 200
milliarden für klima bis zur bundeswehr
sagen sie wenn irgendwas vergessen ist
wir lösen die zunächst mal mit geld um
die krise nicht zu verschärfen
die frage ist wann schaffen hier ist
eben auch eine strategische
neuaufstellung hinzubekommen das läuft
ja parallel muss man vielleicht und das
war die eingangsfrage entschuldigung
muss man den bürgern vielleicht
realistische sagen in welcher situation
wir sind das wäre meine frage an trockel
müssen wir ehrlich sagen dass eine menge
auf uns zukommen kann und übrigens auch
eine menge zumutung und dass wir uns das
eine oder andere vielleicht sparen
müssen und werden wir auf der anderen
seite weniger verteilen können an wen
richtet sich die frauen erst verkommt ja
also ich glaube das muss man zum
ausdruck bringen aber eben zusammen mit
den chancen ich glaube wir müssen ein
wandel der perspektive hinbekommen von
wir bringen euch über die krise hinzu es
gibt eine transformation und die wird
das leben tiefgreifend verändern und
zwar in ganz vielen dimensionen zum
beispiel produkte geschäftsmodelle von
unternehmen
es gibt unternehmen die müssen stück für
stück sich daran gewöhnt etwas ganz
anderes zu machen als sie vorher gemacht
haben zum beispiel in der chemie so
sicher dass die wieder benutzt werden
wir nicht mehr in dem umfang einsetzen
können und an die stelle wird getreten
um weniger am teich die tiere
einzusetzen und gentechnik über einen
relativ langen zeitraum aber da
überlegen sich konzerne natürlich heute
schon steige ich in dieses geschäft ein
das gleiche ziel zu verfolgen mit
unterschiedlichen technologien oder
nutze ich meine expertise der pestizid
produktion um dinge zu produzieren die
auf die klimaneutralität einziehen also
ich in italien zu produzieren die auf
die klimaneutralität einzigen das sind
sehr sehr tiefgreifenden veränderungen
die werden damit einher gehen dass die
menschen sich auch verändern müssen
weiterbilden müssen dass wir fachkräfte
ausbilden müssen die eben für diese
bereiche qualifiziert sind und das sind
müssen wir anfangen zu kommunizieren für
die vielleicht einen punkt noch dazu
eines ist das was der staat macht wo der
staat unterstützt mit geld das andere
sind die privatwirtschaftlichen
investitionen wenn sie
gesamtwirtschaftlich gucken dann sind 90
ungefähr der gesamtwirtschaftlichen
investitionen sind privatwirtschaftliche
investitionen und diese riesentanker der
privatwirtschaftlichen investitionen den
muss man in richtung einer nachhaltigen
entwicklung lenken und das ist eine
große herausforderung beschleunigung von
genehmigungsverfahren wurde schon
angesprochen aber eben auch die
richtigen anreize stichwort zum beispiel
auf der eu ebene haben wir gerade
gesehen dass die verhandlungen in
richtung co2 bepreisung doch c sind die
zahl an kleinen fortschritt
aber wir müssen eigentlich hinkommen in
richtung von rahmenbedingungen die klare
anreize für klimaneutralität setzen auf
europäischer ebene das auch nicht jeder
mitgliedstaat daran herumdoktern kann so
dass die unternehmen klare signale haben
bezüglich das sind welches
geschäftsmodell zahlt dann ein damit
kann ich dann in zukunft man geld
verdienen und umso klarer die
regulierung ist umso weniger
regulatorische unsicherheit die
unternehmen auch haben dass du mehr wird
auch passieren und dass du mehr wir sind
ja müsste man beispielsweise ich frage
ist ganz kurz damit wir nicht gleich
alles korrigieren ich was ich eher
fragen wollte war wie wäre es wenn wir
den leuten
zumuten über das sparen nachzudenken
aber wenn wir
werden wir eben doch wenn wir uns über
tempolimit noch mal unterhalten über den
autofreien sonntag unter also wenn ja
der wirtschaft versteht warum sie habe
die ganze liste der verbote musste zu
dieser falschen ansprache
nicht
glauben ich freundschaft versprecher
aber ich habe den punkt verstanden
mussten trotzdem 19 mitnehmen und muss
man nicht auf der anderen seite halten
sie ist aber etwas anders werden wird
warum sollen wir den leuten jetzt immer
sagen alles ganz schlimm und zu weiter
ich glaube die menschen merken schon was
los ist und ich erwarte von politischer
führung dass ihr nicht die ängste der
menschen vergrößert sondern ja ich nehme
sie ja mit aber auf meine weise ich will
sie nämlich nicht in ihren ängsten
bestätigen sondern ich möchte die
menschen gerne stärken dafür dass im
wandel chancen sind und deshalb mache
ich auch nicht gerne zu sagen wir werden
alle arm das ist eigentlich nicht meine
botschaft meine botschaft ist nicht der
fall genau meine botschaft ist es gibt
chancen für neuen wohlstand und neue
soziale sicherheit wenn wir uns
verändern arm werden wir wenn wir uns in
dieser veränderten lage nicht auch
selbst prüfen aber wenn wir von den
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
angefangen haben jetzt mehrfach betont
über mehr zu tun für bildung und
forschung
unsere fachkräfte problematik lösen die
infrastruktur in deutschland verbessern
freihandelsabkommen mit anderen
weltregionen am hausrat china schließen
damit wir dort eben mit denen die so
ähnlich denken wie wir auch stärker in
wirtschaftliche beziehungen eintreten
saubere technologie entwickeln und so
weiter dann haben wir eine chance unsere
unser wohlstandsmodell und auch die
individuellen aufstiegs geschichten in
deutschland auch zu erneuern und deshalb
nicht angst machen das ist die aufgabe
der politik sondern unsere aufgabe ist
beste rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen
damit hier zukunft passiert wir machen
nicht angst sondern wir fragen uns weil
wir haben christian lindner so zitiert
wir werden ärmer werden und das ist erst
mal der fall weil es ein wertverlust
unseres geldes gibt und glauben sie dass
diese glauben sie dass dieses wir
der solche geburt ist werden manche noch
ärmer als wir alle ja in der tat ist mir
das hört sich alles nett an aber ist mir
ein bisschen zu pauschal wir müssen
schon schritt tiefer gehen und die
wahrheit ist natürlich dass die menschen
in diesem land über verschiedenste
veränderungen die wir schon hinter uns
haben eine erfahrung gemacht haben
nämlich dass die reichen reicher und die
armen ärmer werden und deswegen stellt
sich jetzt so noch mal gerade in so
einer beschleunigten transformation die
frage gelingt es uns diesmal halt
wirklich das sozial gerecht zu machen
das ist das was wir ein verlangen das
heißt wir müssen jetzt schon noch mal in
die in den instrumentenkasten genauer
schauen also eine reine sozusagen
ökologische wende über den privaten
markt und eine co2 bepreisung zu
organisieren halte ich für nonsens wir
sehen ja jetzt gerade was passiert wenn
energiepreise steigen das sind natürlich
vor allem die haushalte mit geringeren
einkommen die besonders darunter leide
wir haben eine inflation die ist ohnehin
nennenswert hoch aber sie ist natürlich
haushalts spezifisch zum teil noch viel
unterschiedlicher kleine einkommen
ich sag mal auch in doppelverdiener
haushalt mit zwei kindern 60.000 euro
bruttojahreseinkommen hat am ende und
pendler vielleicht vielleicht auch noch
hat in diesem jahr mindestens anderthalb
wenn ich 2000 euro zusätzliche belastung
die haben eine viel höhere inflation zu
sagen haushalts spezifische
inflationsrate als andere und deswegen
müssen auch die entlastungs pakete
natürlich zielgenau sein wir begrüßen
dass das ist an dieser stelle durchaus
auch eine
finanzpolitische offensive gibt ob das
zielgerichtet genug ist das sei mal
dahin gestellt also der vorwurf rentner
sind nicht ausreichend berücksichtigt
ihren de sind nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt hier wird auf eine kleine
solo selbstständige sind nicht
ausreichend berücksichtigt das sind
alles themen da müssen wir jetzt schon
mal sehr viel einsparungen genau so
pauschal es liegt in der krise eine
chance ich glaube dass wohl viele
menschen an den monitoren nicht ab wie
inflation hat viele gründe haben wir
gerade schon verstanden aber vor allen
dingen einen leidtragenden nämlich den
verbraucher
einer studie zufolge belastet die
inflation einen durchschnittlichen vier
personen haushalt mit rund
242 euro monatlich haupt belastungen 65
euro mehr für lebensmittel
89 euro bei energiekosten und 40 euro
für verkehrsmittel im jahr bedeutet dass
knapp 3000 euro mehrausgaben durch
inflation
es sind sogar noch mehr herr häuschen
wohnen essen zur arbeit fahren das sind
dinge die kann man sich nicht sparen
darauf kann man nicht verzichten
genau deswegen hat sie recht es geht
darum dass die entlassungs verkehrte
zielgenau sind und dass sie dort wirken
wo sie sozial notwendig sind müssen
sozial ausgewogen sein und dürfen nicht
pauschal sein wir können zum beispiel
über die benzin versenkung
philosophieren dass jetzt auch leute die
sich nicht leisten können mit
leistungsstarken autos durch die gegend
zu fahren davon auch profitieren es
wirklich ist vermutlich mit cd als
unangemessen ist mit sicherheit
unangemessen also ich glaube dass die
soziale ausgewogenheit alle
entlastungsmaßnahmen beachtet werden
muss und dann am ende des tages
vielleicht auch die staatskasse schützt
weil ich irgendwas geld wirklich nur
dort aus gebe wo es wirkt und nicht auch
dort geld ausgebe wo es nicht wirkt
indem ich eben zum beispiel eben leute
die sich leisten können bei den
benzinkosten entlastet was mir aber an
der ganzen diskussion nicht gefällt
werden wieder so darauf
fokussiert was kann der staat eigentlich
tun aber ganz zu recht hat vor den
folgen sagt 90 prozent der medizin in
diesem land kommen aus der
privatwirtschaft und die entscheidende
frage ist eigentlich wie agiert die
privatwirtschaft und unter welchen
bedingungen agiert die privatwirtschaft
und sind wir gleich bei dem thema
rahmenbedingungen sowie das thema
genehmigungsverfahren im planverfahren
angesprochen insgesamt sind wir in eine
umgebung wo die investitionen der
privatwirtschaft gefördert werden müssen
das ist viel wichtiger wie die frage ob
herr lindner 350 milliarden oder 280
milliarden oder 400 milliarden in die
hand nimmt also das ist interessant dass
ich es jetzt noch einmal zusammenfassen
auch dazu werden wir natürlich noch
kommen mal unabhängig davon dass sich
herr lindner jetzt gerade
kaufkraftverlust der bürger natürlich
auch eine unternehmen gesunkene
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der unternehmen
als finanzminister darüber freuen kann
dass er wahrscheinlich der einzige ist
der gerade gewinnt ich glaube wir
sollten auch hier also mir gefällt das
nicht dass wir hier in der breite von
armut sprechen
wir werden mit sicherheit werden wir
werden werden mit mit sicherheit
für eine bestimmte periode reale
einkommensverluste sehen wir gerne auch
wohlstandsverluste sehen wird das dazu
führen dass deutschland arm wird
natürlich nicht so es darf aber auch
nicht sein dass wir glauben dass all das
über staatliche der dämpfen oder
staatliche entlastungs pakete abgefangen
werden kann das wirklich der fall sein
und um so wichtiger ist es dass wir die
sozialschwachen auffangen die davon
wirklich getroffen sind am ende des
saals reden wir sicherlich in gewissem
umfang über eine umverteilung
beziehungsweise stark geschützt sind
werden hier mehr tragen als schwache es
hat nicht jeder ein auto wenn man
festlegen würde dass wir alle energie
sparen und das wir übrigens auch benzin
sparen und dass wir über so was wie
einen sonntag autofreien nachdenken dann
würde das ja nur eine bestimmte zahl der
menschen treffen manche von denen
brauchen dringend ein auto andere haben
3 aber man könnte einfach festlegen dass
man wie damals energie spart also man
kann den bürger mitnehmen
ich bin aber auch nicht ansicht dass das
nicht dass das nicht geschieht also wenn
ich in die wenig die mittel hat seine
mitarbeiter bei uns an strasser als im
unternehmen sei es im maschinenbau dann
ist großes verständnis dafür dass was
passiert übrigens auch für die
transformation die in der
privatwirtschaft schon längst angepackt
wird ganz ganz gut
bei den beschäftigten auch viel
unterstützung gibt und auf chemie kleine
sekunde behalten sie ihren gedanken ich
möchte ihnen gerne den bäckermeister aus
rostock vorstellen denen wir heute
kennen lernen wollen und münzen herrn
grenzer nämlich gut dass sie heute bei
uns in der ganzen sie sind in rostock zu
hause haben eine bäckerei mit 17
angestellten richtig und sie helfen uns
bei der beantwortung dieser frage wie
sehr diese inflation momentan schon ihr
leben ihr geschäft ihren betrieb
beeinflusst sie kaufen zu welchen
preisen ein was sie für ihr
bäckerhandwerk brauchen zu deutlich
erhöhten preisen wie als vor sechs
monaten zum beispiel haben wir vor sechs
monaten für 30 cent einkaufen können
jetzt sind es mittlerweile schon 60 cent
also 100 prozent obendrauf das ist ein
kleiner teil aber auch energie gehört
dazu natürlich auch die spritkosten die
uns beutel zum glück haben wir keine
geschäfte die weit entfernt sind von
unserer backstube wir haben nicht so
große lieferwege aber was machen die
bäckereien die viele filialen haben und
weit fahren müssen
können was von diesen preisen ihrem
ihrer kundschaft zumuten zu welchen
bedingungen verkaufen sie brötchen also
wir können unseren kunden nicht alles
zumuten das heißt dass wir gewisse
preise erhöhen aber wir können auch
nicht alles erkennen weil du ganz genau
wissen dass unsere kundschaft nicht die
kaufkraft hat um um sich mal ein gutes
bäcker brot zu kaufen zum beispiel meine
meinung ist dass das brot nicht zum
luxus artikel werden darf es dürfe nicht
nur bestimmte leute sich das brot
leisler kiep auf das tägliche brot kann
man nicht verzichten und das wird bei
ihnen ein ganz besonderes sein sie sagen
sie sind so dankbar dass auch die kitas
um die ecke
lieber das gute boot
richtig den kindern geben logischerweise
liefern morgens an kindergärten und
pflegeheime und so handwerklich
hergestelltes brot und ich bin auch froh
darüber dass sie das nehmen zum deutlich
erhöhten preis als oder brot industrie
wo sparen ihre kunden glauben sie
sie werden bei unternehmen sparen
spricht kino auch lebensmittel natürlich
und das sehen wir ja auch bei unseren
kunden die die zu uns kommen dann wurden
zwar nicht mehr drei brötchen gekauft
sondern nur noch zwei so spiegelt sich
das wider also wir verkaufen deutlich
weniger und die
diese das ist in form der einsparung
können sich die menschen weniger
verzichten sie auf den cappuccino bei
ihnen sie müssen sie müssen einfach um
irgendwie klar zu kommen um alles
stemmen zu können was auf sie zukommen
und sie haben das gefühl dass die
menschen das auch verstehen wie
reagieren die auch auf eine
preiserhöhung bei ihnen der größte teil
also verstehen dass das wir auch gewisse
preise erhöhen müssen aber es gibt
natürlich auch kunden die dann anfangen
unsere verkäuferin zu beleidigen und den
ganzen frust der sich aufgestaut hat
über die korona zeit bis jetzt sind die
preiserhöhung das lassen sie an den
verkäuferin ab und das bekommt kein
politiker mit sondern 11 die verkäuferin
und die kann nichts dafür und das ist
das problem jetzt könnte es auch mit dem
gas noch ein bisschen knapper werden was
hieße das für sie denken sie schon
darüber könnten sie sparen wir haben
ganz große angst davor dass der gashahn
zugedreht wird weil viele bäckereien aus
gas angewiesen sind wir bereits in
unserem film größtenteils mit gas
wir wissen nicht wie wir das stemmen
sollen also wenn wir jetzt auf strom
umstellen müssten haben viele nicht die
möglichkeit weil unsere ösen auf gas
oder diesel ausgestattet sind und wir
nur damit backen können und sie haben
auch keine sie los und können keine
vorräte anlegen weil sie eben eine
kleine bäckerei sind und keine große
richtig genommen das heißt sie können
auch nicht vorsorgen um jetzt
einigermaßen gut durch diese zeit zu
kommen nein du so möglich haben sie
verständnis für das was diese
bundesregierung tut haben sie
verständnis dafür dass
man prioritäten setzen muss in dieser
situation das ist eben eine zeit wird's
in der
handwerksbetriebe wie der ire eben auch
durch eine schwere zeit gehen ich habe
verständnis dafür ja aber es heißt ja
nicht umsonst dass viele
handwerksbetriebe die wirtschaftsmacht
von nebenan sind das die
wirtschaftsmacht von nebenan
wir arbeiten mit den mit den leuten vor
ort regional für die leute vor ort wir
können nichts aus zossen wir können auch
nicht mit unserer bäckerei jetzt von
rostock nach münchen ziehen das ist
unmöglich
das können industriebetriebe deshalb
brauchen wir auch die unterstützung um
vor ort weiter zu produzieren zu können
es darf nicht nur an industriebetriebe
oder ausgewählte betriebe gehen sondern
wir brauchen auch dann die unterstützung
werden es hart auf hart kommt wir stehen
der regierung weil aber wir brauchen
auch die unterstützung sind sie auch
noch in meister das sehen wir heute
kleidung und wir fragen mal christian
lindner glauben sie herr lindner diese
zwei pakete diese aus hilfspakete
reichen für herrn grenzer die
entlastungs paket
main haben wir zwei dinge die ihnen
direkt betreffen zum einen wird die
sogenannte eeg-umlage auf die energie
abgeschafft jetzt mitte des jahres die
zahlen sie als handwerksbetrieb auch das
heißt da and last mir direkt seine
stromrechnung sie haben ja auch über die
mobilität gesprochen die energie steuer
wird ebenfalls auf das europäische
minimum reduziert davon profitieren sie
und jetzt haben sie gesagt es gibt
kundinnen und kunden bei ihnen die
können sich die preise die sie erhöhen
gegenwärtig nicht leisten und sind in
sorge es kommt auch an der theke dann zu
zu beklagenswerten szenen denen müssen
wir helfen das heißt also den menschen
etwa im bezug der grundsicherung oder
der
wohngeldbezieher der die steigenden
heizkosten entdecken muss denen helfen
wir in dem gezielt die besonders
betroffenen haushalte auch eine
direktzahlung bekommen damit bei ihnen
die inflation nicht so durchschlägt
andere die gut verdienen die können sich
das bäcker brot auch für ein paar cent
oder euro mehr leisten aber die das
nicht können den müssen wir direkt
helfen ich glaube deshalb dass das paket
oder im bad sind es ja mehrere pakete
die wir geschnürt haben über 30
milliarden euro dass die eine gute
balance haben aushilfe für die
wirtschaft auch gerade für die
handwerksbetriebe einerseits und auf der
anderen seite hilfe für die besonders
betroffenen
dann müssen wir nicht dafür sorge tragen
dass jeder egal
in welcher gehaltshöhe er liegt oder hat
hier bezieht sich ein kulturgut
deutsches brot leisten kann ich bin
sofort bei ihnen kommen ja aus einer
bäckerfamilie bis hin zu meinem
urgroßvater also insofern dass das
werben für das kulturgut deutsches brot
angeht finden sie vermutlich niemanden
im bundeskabinett der das so
traditionell wertschätzt wie sie und ich
gebe ihnen recht und deshalb deshalb
sage ich ja gerade wir müssen die
besonders betroffenen also hartz 4
empfänger
grundsicherungsbeziehern die müssen wenn
direkt unterstützen auch durch einkommen
dass der staat auszahlt ich gehe aber
noch einen schritt weiter auch die
breite mitte der gesellschaft auch der
facharbeiter der jetzt nicht bedürftig
ist und sozialleistungen erzählt der
braucht ebenfalls eine unterstützung
eine unterstützung durch die
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber durch
angemessene tarifabschlüsse und auf der
anderen seite durch den staat wenn ich
zum gewinner der sogenannten kalten
progression wird indem er jede
tarifsteigerung die nur die
kaufkraftverluste ausgleicht sofort zum
anlass nimmt um seine steuern darauf zu
sterben matthias grenze aus rostock es
ist toll dass sie heute bei uns sind wir
danken ihnen ganz herzlich und werden
die frage natürlich mitnehmen sie kaufen
anders ein heute sie persönlich sind
ja aber habe ich das gefühl dass sie
sparen müssen zum glück habe ich ja
backwaren zu hause daran liegt nicht
aber wenn ich jetzt meine lieblings
bewusst zum beispiel kaufe sich
natürlich auch den preisunterschied wir
gucken auch in der familie nach
sonderangeboten wie jeder andere auch
aber
wir müssen uns auch einschränkungen wie
wir ihn dann noch mal sogar auch klasse
der sie heute bei uns sind wir
diskutieren weiter und fragen uns wie
häuschen die armen werden unterstützt
die reichen haben und in der
mittelschicht in dem mittelstand muss
jeder gucken wie er über die runden
kommen sie schon spannend das internet
schon in die
tarifverhandlungen hier eingeschlagen
ist und sich für entsprechende belohnung
erhalten einsetzt sehr lobenswert dabei
sicherlich einen vernünftigen kompromiss
finden müssen weil natürlich auch löhne
die inflation beeinflussen der
waldlichtung hoffe ihr anfangs statement
zu bekommen oder zumindest
lohnerhöhungen inflation auch
verfestigen können und ich glaube auch
diese wirklichkeit muss man ins auge
sehen und ich glaube herr linder ist
schon auch erwähnenswert mal auf die
unternehmenssteuern zu gucken
sie wissen das ja gut dass die
unternehmensbesteuerung in deutschland
im internationalen vergleich sehr hoch
ist wir sind ein hochsteuerland und wenn
wir über die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
unternehmen sprechen müssen heute auch
über die unternehmensbesteuerung
sprechen
sagen
bei der unternehmenssteuer bei ist aber
nicht der einzige standort faktor sie
wissen ich wäre der erste der etwas tun
würde
unternehmenssteuern so richtig digitale
infrastruktur auch also ist ja welche
uns noch einiges an so und jetzt werden
wir aber mal auf mit den schlagworten
herausgehen und fragen uns noch mal
zurück zu dem beispiel von herrn grenze
der keine großen möglichkeiten hat
auszuweichen mit seinen beschäftigten
auszuweichen an anderer stelle zu gehen
und gerade nicht so richtig wusste wo er
spart wird und sparen kann wirkt diese
inflation frau fand tatsächlich zu neuen
sozialen frage wird für die ganz armen
nachzubessern sein herr klingbeil spd
vorsitzende hat das angedeutet ja ich
möchte mal auf einen anderen aspekte
eingehen hier sind ja direkt und
indirekt
diverseste verteilungsfragen mal so eben
auch schon heraus angesprochen worden
und ich glaube dass man sie auch
wirklich noch mal auf den punkt
ansprechen muss ich will das noch mal
wiederholen es wird jetzt darum gehen ob
wir in diesen großen herausforderungen
mehr soziale gerechtigkeit walten lassen
das nicht wieder passiert das in dieser
krise nur die armen ärmer werden das hat
viele verteilungspolitische aspekte die
entlastungs pakete haben eine richtige
stoßrichtung aber man muss sich jetzt
genauer anschauen das eben die
haushalts die einkommensschwächsten
haushalte nicht am meisten von diesem
entlastungs paket profitieren da sehen
wir nachbesserungsbedarf
ich sehe aber auch ich sehe vielleicht
habe ich einmal ganz kurz auch meinen
gedanken zu erfahren vielleicht muss ich
glaube sie haben jetzt genügend teile
ihrer darstellung ihrer position gehabt
die zweite frage ist dass wir in einer
situation sind in der wir ja
offensichtlich viele milliarden euro in
die hand wir müssen für
verteidigungspolitische fragen für
investitionspolitik für die
aufrechterhaltung unserer sozialen
systeme für die sicherung von
arbeitsplätzen was kurzarbeit geld
angeht und irgendwann muss man mal die
frage beantworten wer das eigentlich
alles bezahlt das bleibt ist das jetzt
das ist passiert schwarz das ist jetzt
das ist bis jetzt unbeantwortet
wenn es eine tatsache gibt dann ist es
das gewerkschaften immer verantwortliche
tarifabschlüsse machen durch
tarifverträge ist noch kein betrieb in
schwierigkeiten gekommen wir müssen uns
sorgen machen um die bereiche die
überhaupt nicht tarifgebunden sind und
jetzt greife ich gerne mal ein stichwort
von herrn häuschen auf nämlich die frage
inwiefern ist nicht schon auch einen
bedarf der umverteilung in diesem land
gibt in den zwei jahren der pandemie
sind die zehn prozent reichsten
deutschen die schon ohnehin zwei drittel
des gesamt volkswirtschaftlichen
vermögens besitzen noch mal um 100
milliarden reicher geworden und wie viel
historische momente brauchen wir
eigentlich noch um jetzt wirklich auch
mal substanziell zu sagen es bedarf
einer umverteilung von oben nach unten
auf welche art und weise können wir uns
gerne drüber unterhalten ich habe ein
paar vorschläge gemacht vermögenssteuer
lastenausgleich andere dinge und wir
können auch sehr gerne über eine
veränderte einkommenssteuerreform rede
die produktion ja so filialen
reformvorschlag gemacht haben der 95
prozent der haushalte entlasten so sei
sie uns dazu
damit wir wirklich ordnen wir reden über
die einnahmen sinken und über die
ausgaben steigen und da denkt man
natürlich als normaler mensch sofort an
gehaltserhöhungen die helfen könnten
frage also nochmal an den arbeitgeber
erreichen muss nicht logischer weise
schon damit sie die fachkräfte hand
erhalten auch über eine lohnerhöhung
nachgedacht werden wir müssen jetzt
nicht die der stahlindustrie von 82
selbstverständlich braucht es eine
lohnerhöhung das gerät um das es geht um
das maß ich für keine tarifverhandlungen
befindet sich nicht der der die zahl
nennt aber dass wir natürlich eine eine
angemessene erhöhung der entgelte
brauchen ist völlig klar gut und was
sagen sie zu dem vorwurf dass ordentlich
verdient wurde ich glaube auch in diesem
jahr sind also ordentlich verdienen des
kurses ist schlecht aber es sind 70.000
auch nicht gesagt es sind 70 milliarden
geben wir wollen ja auch friedlich
bleiben sind 70 milliarden an die
aktionäre ausgeschüttet worden allein in
diesem jahr das sind ordentliche
renditen oder dividenden korrekter weise
das sind rekordsummen da könnte man ja
auch sagen die sind dann nicht mehr
investierbar sie plädieren immer dass
nicht alle erst zuhören nicht alle
aktionäre sind millionäre und nur ganz
wenige nur ganz ganz wenige aktionäre
die milliardäre
also würde schon mal ganz vorsichtig
sein mit dieser immer wieder
wiederholten these die dividenden kommen
den reichen zu gut es gibt auch ganz
normale menschen die haben auch aktien
und die freuen sich auch über eine
dividende wenn sie dann ist der
kapitalertrag auch ein antrag der ganz
ganz viele menschen so macht der ganz
viele und vielleicht eine große notiert
sind wir noch nicht berühmt als ein volk
von aktionären dass ich
wahnsinnig dran arbeiten jetzt ist
natürlich erstmal die frage wie sorgt
man dafür frau vor mir ich hab es
angesprochen dafür was wäre denn
vernünftig in ihren augen wir führen
hier keine verhandlungen das stimmt aber
wenn die ig metall 8,2 prozent auf ruft
dann klingt das optimistisch ist es auch
realistisch eine solche eine solche
steigerung des gehaltes zu fordern auch
ich spüre keine tarifregelungen drin das
ist sache der ig metall und sie haben
richtigerweise glücklicherweise auch in
diesem land genau eine solche ordnung
dass in den branchen die zuständigen
arbeitgeberverbände und gewerkschaften
miteinander verhandeln weil sie die
kompetenz haben tatsächlich zu
beurteilen was in einer branche
realistisch ist wie sehr es auch um
beschäftigungssicherung geht wie sehr es
um andere arbeitsbedingungen geht und
deswegen führen die verhandlungen die
aber noch mal wir haben immer
verantwortliche tarifverhandlungen
geführt die dieses gesamtpaket im auge
behält und deswegen habe ich überhaupt
gar keinen anlass dazu zu glauben dass
es diesmal anders werden müssen um der
harmonie willen ich will dass
unterstützen also ich glaube dass die
sozialpartnerschaft einer der ganz ganz
großen standort stärken in deutschland
ist am ende des tages hat man sich in
kritischen situationen immer zu
vernünftigen ergebnissen
zusammengefunden das problem ist nur
dass nicht alle davon profitieren
sondern die tarifbindung immer weiter
abnimmt in diesem land und da müssen wir
auch gegen wirken wenn wir die
transformation sozial gerecht gestalten
wollen es wird nicht ohne mehr
tarifbindung gehen ja wobei auch hier
unterstellen sie daß die nicht
tarifgebundenen automatisch schlechter
verein alte tarif gebunden und ich
glaube dass das nicht
das ist ganz eindeutig nachweisbar kann
ich ihn sofort zukommen lassen wir haben
in den vergangenen 30 jahren in
tarifgebundenen bereichen einen
reallohnzuwachs kontinuierliche art und
in den bereichen ohne tarifbindung haben
wir dramatische reallohnverluste gibt es
zahlreiche studien auch von der hans
böckler stiftung leisten gerne sucht so
wir fragen noch mal frau grimm neben den
zweiten gedanken auf müssen reale
einkommensverluste der beschäftigten
hingenommen werden um den standort
deutschland zu retten oder könnte man
tatsächlich wie die gewerkschaft fordert
und nicht nur sie mehr differenzieren
zwischen den menschen die richtig viel
haben und übrigens auch mehr geben
wollten und könnten und in den menschen
die kämpfen die gerade mal so über den
monat kommt also ich denke schon dass um
noch mal auf den auf das eingangs
städten auch zurückbekommen das die
reale lohneinbußen von kompensiert
werden müssen es muss eben ein
gleichgewicht gefunden werden dass die
inflation dadurch nicht so befeuert wird
das ist zu anderen preisspirale kommt
aber ansonsten ist es natürlich so dass
in den tarifverhandlungen die
reallohneinbußen kompensiert werden
müssen ich glaube mit blick auf die
transformation da ist es tatsächlich
wichtig diese gerechtigkeitsfrage zu
stellen aber die lösungen die diskutiert
werden sind oft nicht sehr zielführend
zum beispiel haben wir bei vielen
maßnahmen die in richtung klima
transformationen gehen das sind ganz
vielen maßnahmen die eben gerade sozial
unausgewogen sind zum beispiel die
kaufprämien für autos wer hat denn ein
auto ja die leute die ein auto haben die
sind gehören ja schon zu den
wohlhabenderen viele die wenig haben
können sich ein auto gar nicht leisten
das heißt da geht ganz viel geld in
richtung der wohlhabenderen solardächer
ein solardach die förderung dafür kann
nur derjenige einstreichen da auch im
haushalt
und das sind alles maßnahmen die kosten
stadt sehr viel geld die sind aber auch
teilweise sozial unausgewogen und um
nochmal auf die co2 bepreisung
zurückzukommen das scheint erstmal so
dass es kostensteigerung verursacht aber
man sammelt ja geld ein im moment
gibt es auch hohe risikoprämien zum
beispiel bei investitionen aber die
nutzen ja niemanden dieb abrufen wenn
wir co2 bepreisung machen dann haben wir
einerseits und klare richtung in welche
richtungen die transformation geht was
lohnt sich was lohnt sich nicht und der
staat sammelt geld ein das er dann
gerade nutzen kann um es eben sozial
gerecht wider auszuschütten an
diejenigen die die trans die durch die
transformation nicht zusätzlich belastet
werden und da sie sind richtigerweise
die niedrigen einkommen aber auch ein
großer teil der mittleren einkommen und
ich glaube das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen und da müssen wir richtig
kommunizieren glaube ich aber es ist
eben auch ein bisschen und glaube dass
wir durch ganz viel staatliche
subvention für dies und das tatsächlich
diesen großen tanker in die richtige
richtung lenken können das wird sehr
teuer und am ende brauchen wir aber eben
diese fiskalische tragfähigkeit des
staates auch um zum beispiel für krisen
in krisen agieren zu können also die
vorstellung der staat kann diese ganzen
transformationen finanzieren anschieben
das ist glaube ich auch nur glaube ich
glaube da müssen wir ganz stark auf
anreize setzen und auch dass die ganze
wirtschaft mit macht in die richtige
richtung und jetzt hat muss man das noch
mal ein bisschen ordnung richtig wir
kamen ja ursprünglich daher zu fragen ob
es eine sozial größere ausgewogenheit
geben muss und da gibt's die kritik der
wirtschaftsweisen
grimm zu sagen er lindner dass man
tatsächlich eben den menschen die mir
haben die viel haben in diesem land und
reich sind und auch sagen wo ist der
nächste bildungs soli oder wo ist der
nächste kona soli dass man denen nicht
auch aus gerechtigkeitsgründen etwas
abverlangt darum ist es so schwer also
ich möchte an zwei dinge unterscheiden
wir haben zum einen nur drei dinge sind
sein ich habe zum einen die ich glaube
es erst mal wichtig weil wir wollen ja
argumentativ auch gemeinsam vorankommen
erstens haben die menschen die wirklich
bedürftig sind bei denen die inflation
den unterschied macht am ende des monats
kühlschrank voll oder leer dann geht es
um fragen des sozialstaats der direkt
unterstützt dann gibt es einen zweiten
bereich dass die breite mitte
entschuldigung frau grimm auch die leute
die autofahren auch die leute die ein
eigenes haus haben haben erwartungen das
sind die menschen die mit ihren steuern
und abgaben millionenfach diesen start
am laufen halten und finanzieren und die
möchten auch nicht während der inflation
vollkommen alleine gelassen werden die
wollen auch nicht belastet werden deren
bedürfnisse müssen wir auch sehen ich
will keine kaufprämie für elektroautos
zahlen missverstehen sie mich nicht dass
ich gerade für subventionen werbe aber
ausschließlich auf die bedürftigen zu
schauen wird der mehrheit der
gesellschaft halten wird der mehrheit
der gesellschaft nicht gerecht